[Musique]
le rendez vous était pris au village de
pêche nature à langevin un cadre
magnifique
un temps idéal pour participer aux
animations programmées dans le cadre de
la fête de la nature par les partenaires
de départements à savoir la fédération
départementale de pêche
l'office de l'eau sciences réunion est
aussi edf edf est très fière de
s'associer aux départements pour pouvoir
organiser la fête de la nature de cette
année et accueillir un maximum de
familles pour parcourir des ateliers
scientifiques de talent et de
découvertes et expliquer comment
protéger la faune et la flore de la
réunion on a beaucoup d'action avec la
fédération de pêche pour effectivement
protéger la faune sur le plan d'eau de
l'ange rhin
et aussi on a un atelier pour expliquer
comment maîtriser l'énergie vos enfants
et faire en sorte que l'on émettre moins
de co2 en économisant l'électricité la
fête de la nature est organisé sur l'île
par le conseil départemental en lien
avec le conservatoire international de
la métropole
c'est un événement créé pour valoriser
les atouts de la réunion de la nature
c'est un rendez vous très attendu et
aujourd'hui le département nous
envisageons d'organiser non pas
seulement une fête de la nature mais des
rendez vous nature qui se feront une
fois par trimestre
sur les quatre micro régions de l'île où
chaque réunionnais aura sa place et où
la biodiversité sera encore plus
valorisées la 13e édition de la fête de
la nature ses 19 partenaires et
gestionnaires 25 sites naturels 30
animation et plus de 140 visite guidée
gratuite
[Musique]